Wilkerson:
Okay.
I'm supposed
to start talking now.
I'm Daniel
Shawcross Wilkerson.
I'm here to speak to you
about
distributed transactions
for Google App Engine.
Worked with several
really amazing,
first-rate people
on this project,
and what I can't stand
on my short list of things
I really can't stand
about the media
is this myth
of the lone scientist,
you know, working alone
with his laboratory,
the lone genius coming up
with something amazing.
Most things worth doing
get done by a team.
I would like the media,
anyone watching this,
to please
start acknowledging that
when you write articles.
Simon Goldsmith is
a very good friend of mine
from Berkeley.
He now works at Coverity.
A very smart guy
and very humble.
Robert Johnson is a professor
at Stony Brook.
Another friend of mine
from Berkeley.
He helped us greatly simplify
the locking protocol.
Erick Armbrust at Google
is a really enthusiastic
engineer, great guy,
who found a bug.
Found an optimization.
And also did this little,
minor thing.
He implemented it.
That's a joke.
Ryan Barrett is right here.
Where is Ryan?
Ryan, raise your hand,
'cause I can't see you.
There he is.
Ryan Barrett is at Google
on the App Engine team.
He is, I believe,
in charge of the interface
between App Engine
and BigTable.
And just a very generous guy
with his time
when he knows someone's
trying to do something
with App Engine.
A very humble guy.
A very friendly guy.
And Erick as well.
Great guys at Google.
Let's see.
You'll notice
my corporate affiliation.
It's unemployed.
Case anyone cares
to help remedy that,
let me know.
Afterward, Tony and I
may do a startup,
but if that collapses,
then I'll be talking
to you guys.
So this
is a preliminary report.
What does that mean?
We thought we had this thing
nailed down months ago,
and then we just kept
finding ways to improve it.
And, you know, you can't
resist those things.
Once you find one,
you have to do it.
The only problem
is once you prove it,
you have to prove it
correct again.
And as we'll see,
much of the challenge
to this algorithm--
It's a very
simple looking algorithm.
Don't let that fool you.
Distributed algorithms
and those involving
multi-threading
and distributed...together
are very, very difficult
to debug.
They're basically
impossible to debug.
You have to prove them correct.
So this isn't so much
the algorithm,
but the algorithm plus
proof of correctness.
Yesterday I was
really checking it
to make sure
it was really right
and didn't have any extra parts
and the proof was tight
and the algorithm was tight,
and I'm very convinced now.
But we didn't want
to release it to you
till we, you know,
all looked at it
and made sure
that was the case.
So we'll be releasing this
probably in the next month
or so--the paper--
and Erick
has been following along
with an implementation
as we've been
revising the paper,
and we hope to get that out
somewhere around
the next month or so.
Sorry, Erick,
for inventing the vaporware
and signing you up
for something
without asking you.
Erick is away at a wedding
and Simon's in Europe
and Rob's in New York,
but Ryan is here
and I am here.
What is the fundamental concern
that hits most engineers
when they start
writing software?
There are many concerns,
but two of the fundamental ones
that engineers run into
is correctness
and performance.
Correctness.
Is the output
what you really wanted?
Performance.
How much did that cost?
There's no
getting around this.
This is a timeless problem.
What I don't like
about most talks
about distributed computing
or transactions or databases--
anything--systems
or almost
any talk you go to
in computer science,
they'll start talking about,
"Wouldn't it be cool
if we could enforce
the isolation
of these objects,"
or, "If we could do
these transactions faster..."
And it's like,
"Why do I need transactions?
"Why would I want them?
"Do I want transactions?
No, they're annoying.
"I don't want
to deal with transactions.
I just want to write my code."
Right?
So when
I'm presenting something,
you got to start
with what you actually want.
So instead of a script
going forward,
this is more like a makefile
going backward
from the ultimate goal.
The ultimate goal
is I have a program
that I would like to run.
And it should be correct
to do what I want,
and it shouldn't cost very much.
And I think basically all talks
should start this way.
But from here we can motivate
why you need transactions.
And Brian said,
"You know,
people at this talk,
"they're really gonna want
to see the details.
"They're gonna
want to know the details
of how this thing works."
I go to a lot
of technical talks,
and I'm not an idiot.
And I've been to
a lot of talks at Berkeley
where some
incredibly detailed thing
that I can't follow
after two minutes,
and then I have to sit there,
'cause I can't leave the room
'cause it would be impolite
for another 40 minutes,
and, "oh, my god,
I'm gonna fall asleep."
I don't want to give
a talk like that.
So the details
of this algorithm,
they're subtle,
the proof is very subtle.
I'm not gonna pretend
to give it to you
during this talk.
I'm gonna tell you
why you should care.
You can read it yourself
or you can trust us.
The implementation
will be open source.
But hopefully
what you'll get out of this
is why do you care
about transactions,
why do you need them
for distributed computing,
and why this is the future
and you absolutely cannot
avoid learning about it.
There's no more avoiding
learning about this.
By the way,
this talk was originally
written to be, like,
about 25 minutes,
'cause I gave it
at CodeCon 2009.
If you guys never been
to CodeCon,
be sure to go next year.
It's more like a party.
It's a un-conference.
It's kind of the opposite
of how managed this is.
A lot of good stuff is there.
Most people
don't hear about it.
So if I'm giving a talk
and I've got it designed
for 25 minutes
and I have 60 minutes,
what I'd really like
you guys to do
is just raise your hand
if you have a question.
And I'll probably wait
to the end of my sentence
or the end of my paragraph,
and then I'll probably
take your question.
If your question
is completely off the wall,
then I'm gonna maybe say,
"Well, let's prune that,
or talk about it offline,"
but go ahead and feel free.
I can't stand sitting in a talk
not knowing what's going on,
so raise your hand.
When you do it,
you all look very small,
so raise your hand high
like that.
You know, don't do this,
'cause I'm wondering,
are you fixing your hair?
But feel free. Please.
It's much more fun
to have a conversation.
Correctness
is our primary concern,
and it requires invariants.
A lot of people
who didn't spend
a lot of their time
in a computer science
or math department
don't think about invariants,
but if you really want
to think about
the correctness
of your code,
especially in domains
where it's getting
harder and harder
to debug code,
distributed parallel stuff,
it's just impossible
to debug it.
'Cause you may have a bug,
and it's just unreproducible.
How are you gonna debug it?
You're not gonna run it
in debugger.
Unless you've got
some really clever--
There are some
clever infrastructures
people build to try
to make them reproducible,
but then
you got to learn that.
So the way to think about
the correctness of your code is,
what doesn't change while
all this stuff is changing?
I've heard someone say,
"The essence of software
has changed."
So you want stuff to happen,
but you also want
some other stuff
to not happen.
So computers make it easy
to say what you want
and have it happen.
They also make it real easy
to say what you really
did not want
and have it happen.
This is
a fundamental problem.
So invariants are sentences
that are always true.
they do not change
when all else is changing.
I should have put
one more thing on this slide.
You decide
what should not move.
You know, my data structures
maybe have invariants.
I'll give a few examples.
You initialize them
when you construct
your data structures
or your objects.
You maintain them
during operation
as you do things.
Okay?
And the third thing
you want to do is,
you want to pick invariants
whereby you can insure
the correctness of your code
if you know
they're always true.
And you'll see
what I mean by that
when you see the examples.
If you aren't thinking
in terms of invariants,
start now.
Software is becoming
more and more and more critical
to our infrastructure.
Bugs are just more and more
and more devastating.
People die now
'cause of software bugs.
Okay? It's not a joke.
So you have to start
thinking about this.
If you get nothing else
out of my talk,
remember this--
invariants
and code correctness.
Here's an example invariant.
You have
a doubly-linked list.
This example
is due to Scott McPeak.
People think you can't do
automated
proofs of correctness,
but you can now.
His PhD thesis at Berkeley
was a C compiler
that could prove
some memory drivers
in Linux memory save.
Some, sorry, driver's
memory save in Linux.
It's the sort of thing
you should start thinking about.
This is really
a talk about correctness.
So the invariant that he liked
to give a demo of
was a doubly-linked list.
You either want x->next
to be null,
or you want x->next->prev
to equal x.
If that is ever not true,
you've got a problem.
Further, you don't
just want it to be true.
You want--If it's
a multi-threaded program--
Sometimes you have
to modify your list, right?
You have to add an element
in the middle of your list
or at the end.
Temporarily,
this invariant may be violated.
What you really want
is no other thread can see that,
and you want that when
you violate the invariant,
you don't end up
in this violated state,
that you get
to another good state.
Those are
isolation and atomicity,
which are
two properties we want
of databases, right?
But it's not just about
databases anymore.
Transactions and correctness,
it's not just about
databases anymore.
It's about
all of your software.
Many other data structures
have similar invariants.
You know,
"Don't turn off your computer
"without shutting it down,
'cause your file system
could get corrupted."
Boy,
that was a good idea.
Let's design
our software that way.
No. Let's not
do that anymore, okay?
It's because they're missing
the transaction semantics
in the file system.
Here's another invariant.
Conservation of money.
You're implementing a bank.
When you transfer money
from Alice to Bob,
no money is transferred,
right?
You're just subtracting
an adding.
There's an illusion
of transferring an object,
but why does
that illusion persist?
The illusion persists
because there are invariants
that are maintained.
For example, the sum
of all money does not change.
If money goes away somewhere,
it has to show up
somewhere else.
Local conservation of money
is what makes money work.
If we could just invent money,
it wouldn't be money, right?
All right.
We'll get back to that
invariant, that example.
Scalability.
We'd really like
our software to scale now.
And that's why, you know,
lots of people come
to Google App Engine
conferences.
It's the whole thing
Google does is,
"Let's do all this cool stuff
and make it scalable."
This is a great idea,
but you're not gonna do it
with a big computer.
Gee, Google must just have
this really big computer,
right?
That's how they do all that.
They just have this huge,
honking computer.
No, they don't.
They have
a deconstructed semantics.
They figure out how
to deconstruct
what they're doing
so they can spread it out
over a whole bunch
of little computers.
There's no way around that.
There's no such thing
as this mythological,
big, powerful computer.
Unbounded
performance scalability.
The people who are enthusiastic
about App Engine, it's great.
If you write
your app the right way,
it just scales and scales
and scales and scales,
and it just keeps going.
That's awesome, isn't it?
And there's only
a finite amount of stuff
you have to deal with
to make your app do that,
but there is some stuff
you have to deal with.
So the illusion
many of us grew up with,
you know, I grew up programming
an Atari 800 in BASIC,
and, you know, you're
programming this computer.
It does what you want.
But it was single-threaded.
It didn't turn itself off
at random times.
The hardware--
I had one piece of hardware
and it never failed.
I suppose it could have.
But in a big, distributed--
If your app is scaling
across this huge data center,
computers that
are running your app
will be failing.
I'm sure there's Google people
here besides Ryan.
They can confirm that
Google's just losing machines
every second, probably.
They're just
losing them constantly.
Things become disconnected.
Things go away.
So distributed machines
have,
if we can call them that,
or clusters of machines,
have the following
characteristics,
which are very annoying.
They're not reliable,
as I said.
They're not serial.
Many threads
are happening all at once.
Most people, the way
they write data-structure code,
if there were two threads
manipulating it,
it would be a mess.
You don't want that.
And they're non-synchronized.
There's no single ringmaster
coordinating everything,
making it all coordinated.
And not only that,
there's not even
a global notion of time.
If you've got
a distributed algorithm,
and it's got a global notion
of wall-clock time in it
in order to insure
its correctness,
you're gonna have a bug.
Something's wrong.
This is the future.
You might as well learn it.
This is what
we all have to deal with,
but it's a finite
problem to deal with.
Especially if you have...
[clears throat]
Well, okay, so--shoot.
I thought the next slide
was something else.
Okay,
distributed computing
makes maintaining
invariants hard.
We have to maintain invariants
in order to have correctness.
We want performance,
unlimited scalability,
so we need
to distribute this.
When these two meet,
it's difficult.
Here's why.
Alice sends $10 to Bob.
This time it's $10.
I don't know why.
Okay, step one,
add $10 to Bob's account.
Step two...
Oops,
we didn't get to step two.
Process times out
and machine crashes.
$10 is never subtracted
from Alice's account.
If you're the
federal government,
this is not a problem,
'cause you can just
create money,
as we've noticed recently.
They can create a lot of money.
But most of us are not
the federal government.
We don't work
for the federal government,
so we're not allowed
to do that.
How do we solve this problem?
Transactions.
Transactions are where
maintaining
invariants correctness
meets unlimited scalability.
It's called a "good" state,
a state where all of your
invariants are satisfied.
Your program
is in a good state.
It has all the properties
the user wants.
Good. Leave it that way.
Don't change anything.
If the user says,
"I'd like you
to compute
a service for me," no.
Don't change anything.
That'll preserve correctness.
The only problem is,
it won't give you
any performance,
so in order
to get performance,
we have to temporarily
violate invariants.
You know,
we have a data structure.
It's supposed
to point like this.
Well, you're gonna
change one pointer,
then you're gonna
change the next pointer.
In between,
you've violated the invariant.
If that state were visible
to someone else,
that would be bad.
So what we want to do is,
we want to have
a set of operations
that takes us
from one good state
where all our invariants
are satisfied
to another good state
where all our invariants
are satisfied.
I'm used to thinking this way,
but maybe some people aren't.
People talk about
the design space
or the state space.
You can imagine all
the variables in your program,
all the pointers
and everything,
it's this huge, horrible,
high-dimensional space.
There are certain islands
in that space
which are the good points,
and what you really want to do,
and everything else
is horrible, right?
Badness.
And this space is,
the good set,
is very non-convex.
It's very non-local.
You have to go through badness
to get to other goodness, okay?
So there's islands
of good states,
and you would like to hop
from one island to the other
and not fall in the ocean.
If you think that way,
it's very easy.
So a transaction
is a set of operations
to get us from
one good state to another.
If they satisfy all the
transaction properties, that is.
You first start hearing
about transactions in school,
and they say,
"ACID properties. ACID."
And they say it
over and over and over.
And they say it in every class.
You get books on transactions,
and they'll say--even Gray's
famous book on transactions,
I actually
read a lot of that.
He says the ACID properties,
and then the next page
he says them again.
Sometimes he says them
twice on the same page.
Why doesn't he say it
one time, you know?
And then I started thinking,
you know,
why are these
four properties enough?
Like, are these four properties
what we really need?
I've never seen this
ever written down anywhere,
so I wrote it down.
Actually motivate--Why do we
need these four properties?
If you're hopping
from island to island,
first of all,
when you hop to an island,
you'd like
to actually stay there.
That's called durability.
It's got to have a big,
fancy, Latin name,
because we couldn't
explain anything simply.
I don't know why.
That's academia.
So, atomicity.
We would like it that
you don't fall in the ocean.
Okay, that's atomicity.
You either hop there
or you don't.
It's okay if you try
to hop to an island
and your plane gets cancelled
and you stay at home.
That's okay, 'cause
you're still on an island.
Isolation is that
nobody else can observe
your in-between state
between one island
and the next island.
These are really
the same property.
These are like,
there is no in-between time,
semantically, between...
for yourself, atomicity,
or others, isolation.
Consistency.
Jump, hop from one island
to another island.
Don't hop
to the middle of the ocean.
That's really
the responsibility
of the layer above,
and durability
is really the responsibility
of the layer below.
So all we really need
to concentrate on
when we're using, say,
Google App Engine...
Underneath is a lot
of good infrastructure
by people like Ryan,
and others I'm sure,
that provide durability
and a lot of other properties.
So you can
count on App Engine
to keep your data
once you've put it,
and that put comes come back.
You know, it's replicated.
We heard earlier today
in a different talk,
it's in at least three
different places,
and it's geographically
distributed, good.
I think that's good enough.
It's up to you
as the application developer
to hop from good state
to good state,
to say,
"Run this transaction.
Take me from this state
to another good state."
But the in-between layer,
the transactional layer
I'm gonna talk about,
the distributed transaction
layer I'm gonna tell you about,
we need to be worried
about atomicy and isolation.
And here ACID is again.
I don't know
why I put that in.
All right.
So no questions yet so far?
Nobody's like,
"What is he talking about?"
No? Okay.
Local transactions.
Google App Engine
provides local transactions.
They provide some
transactional semantics.
These guys aren't dumb.
They're at Google.
They said, "Obviously
people need transactions."
But for various underlying
implementation reasons
that Ryan could tell you
a lot about,
and I think he actually will
in his next talk.
It really helps them
to localize the transactions
in space, or what we call
space in data.
So, in other words,
when you make an object
in App Engine,
you can group it
with other objects,
and make something
called entity group.
Once you've done that,
that's it.
You get to pick
the entity group of your object
at object construction time.
You can't move objects
from group to group.
There's no such thing.
Okay,
so these entity groups
form a partition of your data.
And I think the suggested size
in the documentation is,
"Well, that's enough
for one user's data."
Um, yeah, okay,
but maybe my users
would like to interact.
There's this Web 2.0 thing.
Okay. Maybe I'd like
to build a bank.
You can't build a bank
on App Engine right now,
because you can't put
everybody's bank account
into one entity group
that'll overwhelm...
I mean,
you could, technically,
but something would break,
because it would overwhelm...
they've assumed the entity
groups have a certain size,
and it's not that big.
It's about the data
for one user, like I said.
That's what they say.
So how do we
solve this problem?
We would like transactions,
but with local transactions,
you run a transaction,
you'd better only operate
on data in one entity group,
'cause you try
to operate on two,
you get an exception,
I believe, right, Ryan?
You get an exception
if you try to--Yeah.
And also if you try
to run queries,
you can't do that either.
We're not gonna solve--
So we're gonna solve
the first problem,
not the second problem.
So those of you who come
from the relational world,
everything's done with a query.
You can't look up an object
without running a query.
In App Engine, if you have
the key to an object,
you can get it
and you can put it
without running a query.
There's something else
called a query.
We're not gonna solve
the problem called
"You can't run queries
in a transaction on App Engine."
That's future work.
We are gonna
solve the problem called,
"You can't do transactions
"across a set of objects
that span
more than one entity group."
We're gonna solve that problem.
You haven't been able
to do that until now.
Any questions so far?
That's the problem.
And why you should care.
Solution.
Well, this is the algorithm.
That's it.
Fits on one slide.
I'll read it to you.
The first thing is...
What we're gonna do is,
we basically want the user,
when they run a transaction,
they're gonna
read some objects,
they're gonna read something,
maybe from the user,
and they're gonna
write some objects.
We want that to look
to all other threads
as if it happened
instantaneously.
So the database
was in some state,
and then when the user--
they mapped basically
reads to writes,
and that happened
in one instant in time.
Now,
it doesn't really happen
in an instant in time,
so we have to provide
that illusion.
Semantically, it happens
in an instant in time,
but we're separating that
from how it actually runs.
So what we do is,
first of all,
when the client says,
"Here's a function
and here's some arguments,
run this in a transaction
for me."
That's the interface.
You say,
"Run in transaction."
Hand it a client function.
When the client
asks for reads,
when they say, "Read these
objects from the database,"
we read them then,
but we record
the version number
of the object read.
All objects
get a version number.
And they can't roll over.
I'll tell you about that later.
Then the client function says,
"Hey, write these objects
back to the database."
We don't do that.
That could be bad.
That could break something.
So we're not gonna write
any of your data.
So we said instead
we store the writes
in these shadow objects,
and if you try
to write a user object
in the client function,
we store that, what you wrote,
in a shadow object
in the same entity group
as the user object.
So we spread your data out.
It's in many different
entity groups.
It's cool.
It's all gonna work.
Now the client function
is done.
I should have put that in here.
So the client function is done.
The map it computes
from reads to writes,
that's now a static object
of finite size.
This is very handy for us.
So now what we do is,
we get write locks
on all the objects
we're gonna write.
Now if we just do that
in any order,
what can happen?
'Cause write locks
exclude each other,
so no two
distributor's transactions
can have a write lock
on the same user object
at the same time.
What can happen
if you just get write locks?
Deadlock.
Somebody said it.
Because, "I need this,"
and "You need that,"
and we all grab,
and we just sort of wait,
'cause none of us can get
what we need to finish,
but we're not about to let go
of the resources we have,
so we just stay there
in deadlock.
All right, so instead,
the standard algorithm
for getting rid of that,
sort your objects,
get them in increasing order.
You can't get a cycle,
because your wait-for graph
is only pointing up the order.
Then we go
and check the version numbers
on all the objects you read
to see if they still have
the same versions they had
when you read them.
Now some of you are saying,
"But that's a race condition,
Dan.
They could change
after you check."
No, it'll work.
Trust me.
Someone should say,
"Race condition?"
Come on.
You guys are just sitting there.
It's much more fun
if you say something.
Okay. We also check not only
is the version the same,
but nobody else
is in write lock
on that read object.
And then we're gonna
go do something later.
It's not a race condition.
Then we go and we
take all the shadows
and we copy them, stomping on
the state of the user object.
We make your write
actually for real.
We copy the shadow object
to the user object state.
We update the version number,
which is actually the ID
of the distributed
transaction object.
IDs are guaranteed
never to repeat.
Ah-ha.
So version numbers
can't roll over.
And then we delete
the write locks
and the shadow objects
leaving no garbage.
There's a very subtle,
very rare condition
under which we can still
get garbage in this algorithm.
I'm working on it.
If I told you,
Ryan would say,
"Dan, that'll never happen."
Well, I don't know
what he would say.
Sorry, Ryan.
But I'm obsessive
about these things.
See, that's what you want.
You want someone
designing this algorithm
to be obsessive.
All right, there's a lot
of things you can do.
That's all
the correctness depends on.
There's some things you can do
so that transactions
kind of try
not to stomp on each other.
Ah. Yes.
We have a question.
Thank you.
I'll repeat the question.
If I got write locks,
why do I then check
that the objects
don't have write locks?
I get write locks
on all the objects I write.
For all the objects I read,
which could be a different
set of objects.
I check the version numbers
are still good,
so no one else has written it,
and no one else has it locked.
No one else has the objects
I read write locked.
'Cause you could read
some objects and write others.
You tend to read and then
write the same objects,
but it could be
separate sets of objects.
Good question. Thank you.
Yes.
And if you're near the mic,
please use the mic.
man: This is similar
to phase commit...
Wilkerson:
It's--yeah.
There's only so many
good ideas in this world.
man: How do you prevent
a client from crashing?
Wilkerson: I'm not
gonna patent this. Yes?
man: How do you
prevent the locks
from being held indefinitely
when a client crashes?
Wilkerson:
How do I prevent the locks
from being held indefinitely
if someone crashes?
Very good question.
Okay.
So a lot of the complexity
of the algorithm
goes into these concerns.
This is very simple,
but there's lots of things
that can go wrong.
I'll actually
talk about that later,
but I'll answer it now.
Which is, if you grab
some write locks
and then you just crash,
your thread crashes,
first of all,
all the state of
the distributed transaction
is stored in the distributed
transaction object,
which is also in the database,
and we don't start
rolling it forward
until it's in the database.
So you grab some locks,
and then your thread
goes away.
Someone else
tries to lock that object,
they block,
'cause you have the lock.
They can check
your creation time of the--
So distributed
transaction one
gets a lock on an object.
Distributed transaction two
tries to get it.
Distributed
transaction one's thread
is timed out or something.
Distributed transaction two--
Since all the state of
the distributed transactions
is in the database,
its thread can pause,
go and become the thread
that's rolling forward this one
that has the lock,
roll it forward to completion,
then go back
and complete itself.
So the entire state
of the distributed transaction
is in the database as well.
So different threads
can kind of switch off
and roll forward different
distributed transactions
if they're blocking.
That's the answer.
Make sense?
Transactions and cooperate.
If you are reading an object
and, hey,
it has a write lock,
you probably ought to wait.
That's pretty much it.
That probably works.
This is all
not as easy as it looks.
In case you're wondering,
why'd this guy
get to talk at Google IO?
I could have done this
in a weekend.
Deadlock prevention,
yeah, you've got to do that.
But deadlock prevention
prevents a lot
of other cool stuff.
If you've got to sort
all the objects you're writing,
what that means is
the client has to be done
writing them.
So you have to do it
after a client's done writing,
and these restrictions begin
to accumulate ongoing progress.
There's a lot of things
that can cause...
There's a lot of ways
to deal with ongoing progress.
This is--it's a big topic.
One is your thread
can go away.
Someone else needs to be able
to roll you forward.
But what if no one does
try to get a write lock
on one of your objects
and no one
tries to roll you forward?
Well, you need
a background thread
that's looking for old
distributed transactions
and rolling them forward.
Also,
how do you prevent the user
from accumulating unsatisfied
distributed transactions?
We thought a lot
about how to,
or I thought about
how not to...
One of the things Gray
talks about in his book
on databases,
he has this huge book
the size of a calculus book
on databases,
and then he has
this one little aside.
It's, like,
a page and a half.
He says, "But this reality
can become completely decoupled
from what's in the database."
For example, something
that actually happened,
in a branch office of this,
like, bank,
they took all the records,
and they hid them
in the ladies' room.
And they never got entered
in the database.
So keeping your database
synchronized
with the user interface
is actually part of our paper.
So we actually record the user,
the request of the
distributed transactions,
so that, A, well, when you get
another request from a user,
first thing you can do
is query for all the pending
distributed transactions
they haven't finished
and roll those forward first,
so the user has an experience
of transactions committing
in the order in which
they requested them.
I think that's important,
you know.
In algorithms class
they've never
probably talked about that,
but this is reality.
Concurrent roll-forward.
The second half
of the algorithm,
where once the client
function is finished...
If other threads can come
and start rolling your
distributed transaction forward,
there can be multiple threads
doing that, right?
So that means
your entire roll-forward
has to be thread-safe.
But how do you do that?
Because I have to get locks,
and then release them later.
That's not item potent, right?
Item potent
means I do something
and then it's done,
I never go back.
Or like a light switch.
You switch it on,
no matter how many times
you switch it on, it's on.
It's not a toggle switch.
Toggle switches
are not item potent.
They're also not thread-safe.
Because if I went
and turned the lights on,
another thread could come
and hit the button also
and then turn 'em off.
And, no, I want 'em on,
and they come
and turn 'em off again.
I want it on.
And two people trying
to turn on a toggle switch,
they could fight with each other
and keep turning the lights off.
This is not thread safe,
so you need your entire process
of getting the locks
and releasing them
to somehow be thread-safe.
And I'll leave that as a puzzle
for the listener.
How do you get a lock
and then release it
in a way that's item potent?
Erick Armbrust
came up with a way to do that.
It's really clever.
By accident, actually,
in a sense.
We didn't realize
he solved that problem.
Proof of isolation.
We need to guarantee
all these properties
where no one can see
things happening in between.
So, deadlock prevention,
we talked about that.
Get locks in a certain order.
Ongoing progress,
oh, yeah.
We want read-storms.
I think Ryan
once said in a talk,
found that Google
has ten to a hundred times
as many reads per writes
in web apps.
So this is optimized so that
if you have a write
and lots of people
are reading that object,
those reads
can't keep out your write.
Some of this
I already talked about,
rolling forward
when you're blocked.
We take care
not to create garbage,
which is actually
kind of hard to do.
I talked about
concurrent rollforward,
so when we're getting locks,
we want to proceed--
We want the state space
of our distributed transaction
to proceed monotonically
through some big state space
where there's only one path,
so multiple threads
rolling it forward won't matter,
'cause they're all
going along the same path.
So they'll all
get to the same place.
And this is more about that.
So this says the answer.
But can anybody else
figure out how,
looking at this
and thinking about it,
how do you release a lock
in an item-potent way?
When we created
the need for the lock,
we wrote a shadow object.
So first you have
a shadow object.
Then you have a shadow object
and a lock.
Then you delete the lock
and the shadow object
at the same time
in a local transaction.
So those
are three distinct states
that actually aren't repeating.
Even though the lock is getting
set and then released,
the whole state's base
is still monotonic.
Locally,
it looks non-item potent,
but it isn't.
Strong consistency.
Eventual consistency
is this new fad
in distributed algorithms
where you don't have
to actually make sure
everybody else finds out
when you update objects,
but that's a real pain
to program too.
Thankfully...
Ryan is nodding.
Thankfully
the good people at Google
on the App Engine team
have provided us
with a strong consistency,
which means if I update
an object and it returns,
then anybody else
I talk to subsequently,
if they look,
they're gonna see that update.
There's something in between
called causal consistency,
where I can tell certain people
and they're guaranteed to know.
You could actually
do our algorithm
on top of causal consistency,
but we have strong consistency,
so we don't need it.
Without strong consistency,
it's very, very funky
what does time mean
in a distributed algorithm.
Local and distributed
transactions don't mix.
Local transactions
are obviously cheaper.
They have less mechanisms.
So Erick has carefully
implemented this algorithm
so that if you only need
distributed transactions
for certain objects,
you can have them
only for those objects
and not use them
for other objects.
Also, you really don't want
to mix them accidentally,
because local transactions
don't honor our
distributed transaction locks,
so there's no way with
the way Erick has it set up,
at least the way he told me,
is there's no way to use
distributed transactions
on an object without entering
the distributed transaction
infrastructure.
You can't use a DT.
If you do,
you're objects suddenly
become DT flavored,
and you are using
distributed transactions.
We did a lot of work
to try to prevent you guys
from falling into holes.
Like, if you use
the algorithm just right,
everything's fine,
and then
if you do something wrong,
too bad for you,
'cause you're the stupid user.
No.
We didn't do that.
We really tried to make it
so that it's fool-proof,
so that you guys
don't fall into holes.
Also, there's a thing
if we're buffering writes
from an algorithm I read,
object x, I get x is 1.
Then I write x is 2.
Then I read object x again,
I'm gonna get x is 1,
'cause it's a buffered write.
So we prevent that
from happening.
We don't allow you
to do read after write.
We also don't allow you
to do write after write,
but again,
this allows the illusion
of correct data flow
in your client code,
so that you're not--
we're not messing you up.
Even though we're messing
with the data flow,
you can't see that.
So you can't mess yourself up
by using our infrastructure
that way.
Also failed DTs
throw an exception.
Oops.
That's not true any more.
Anyway, we leave distributed
transactions around
after they're completed,
so you can query them.
See, distributed
transactions are...
They're synchronous issue
and asynchronous complete.
You don't know
when they'll complete,
'cause your thread
might time out.
So they stay in the database
so that other threads
of your application
can actually report
that to the user.
This action you took, user,
I'm imagining an Ajax UI.
We're in another window.
You say, you know,
"This action
you took succeeded.
"This one succeeded.
Sorry, this one failed.
"You might want to retry that.
"But since
the database has changed,
you might want to check it out
before you retry it."
So you can really have
a very professional
conversation with the user.
"These are
exactly what succeeded,
This is exactly what failed."
The user
doesn't have to guess.
And then the client code,
the calling client code,
can delete the distributed
transaction objects
when it's sure
it has informed the user,
and the user knows
what they need to know.
So this is a way
to really do crisp apps
with very clean semantics,
where there's nothing
funny like,
"Oh, I did something,
and, well, it didn't happen.
I wonder why."
You know, you can find out.
The user can find out.
So the whole vision
is to write
enterprise-ready apps
where you can write a bank,
and, you know,
if you try to transfer money
and it doesn't happen,
you can tell
the user precisely,
"That did not happen.
For sure it didn't happen."
Not, "Oh, this seems to--
I guess it doesn't seem
to have happened."
We don't handle queries.
That's because
queries are hard.
The ability to handle queries
depends a lot on the semantics
of the query predicate.
Also even local transactions
in App Engine
do not honor queries.
Ryan is nodding his head.
But soon maybe some of them?
Oh, sorry.
Maybe I shouldn't
have said that.
Oops. Sorry.
No.
[laughing]
They don't handle...
So queries are really tough.
And one thing you can do,
and I'm not quite sure
what the semantics is,
but you can do a query
and then take
all the objects you got
and mark them as read
in a distributive transaction,
and that
will give you something.
But I'd have to think
exactly what it would give you.
We need future work on that.
Maybe Google will hire me
to work on that.
I don't know.
They have a hiring freeze.
He tried to get me hired,
but they have a hiring freeze.
ACID correctness
example isolation.
Ah, yes.
Here's an example
of why you need ACID.
This is from Simon.
So distributed
transaction one
gets write locks
on two objects,
and has written object A.
It has written
the new balance for Alice,
but not the new balance
for Bob.
The other
distributed transaction--
Oh, and then DT1 is paused.
I don't know.
Gets swapped out
or gets scheduled out.
DT2 now comes and reads
the state of A and B.
So it sees that Alice
has lost $10,
but not that Bob has gained
$10, or whichever.
DT2 has read
a state of the database
that does not
satisfy the invariant.
DT2 must die.
It must be doomed.
We cannot let it complete.
We must abort DT2.
And we do guarantee
that if this happens,
DT2 will abort,
and the reason it will abort
is because when DT2--
when it goes to commit,
when DT2 checks
the version number
for object B,
it will fail.
Well, there'll be either
a lock on object B,
or the version number check
will fail.
Oh, yeah, this is--
Yeah, there'll be a lock,
so it'll fail.
Anyway, there's various
different ways it can fail
depending on
when things get scheduled,
but it will definitely fail.
Here's that example written out
in painful detail.
I'm not sure if you really want
me to go through this example.
Anybody want me
to go through it?
Wow. Nope. Okay.
Future work.
We'd like to do queries.
It's very dependent
on the predicate.
We need the--
Do we really need to rely
on underlying
strong consistency?
Google App Engine provides it,
so that's cool,
but maybe you could use this
on other infrastructures.
We don't actually
provide strong consistency
to some degree.
You have to do queries
to find out
when you issue a transaction,
you know,
did it complete?
So you can kind of do it,
but you've got to keep asking,
"Did this distributed
transaction complete?"
So you can probably get it
if you work.
We can add that.
Performance.
I'm not an expert
on the deep,
underlying layers
under Google App Engine,
but Erick Armbrust
at least did
one really cool optimization
where shadow objects
actually aren't
manifested as objects.
They're just a string
which is in the protocol
that Google sends over the wire
to other machines.
So there are people at Google--
The reason to do this
is open source,
is because, you know,
people at Google
can help me get it right, A,
and, B, do the cool
optimizations underneath,
and, C, I get
to come talk to you guys.
So...conclusion.
Ryan said, "You have to have
a conclusion slide."
What does it say?
"Distributed Transactions
on Google App Engine exist."
Or sometime
in the next month or two
we'll get them released.
And let us know
if they help you,
or let me know,
I guess,
or write any of us,
I suppose.
Probably Ryan would want
to hear from you as well.
Yeah,
he's nodding his head.
That's pretty much it.
I'd love to take questions
if you have them.
Thank you.
[applause]
Yes, sir.
Would you guys
mind using the mics?
They asked me to ask you
to use the mics.
I can repeat questions
if you're in a wheelchair
or something, but...
man: So is this gonna be
a library that's released
that we can use
in our application,
or is it gonna be built
in the Google App Engine
itself?
Wilkerson:
Erick Armbrust
is releasing
his implementation
as a personal, open-source
project at Google.
So it will be released
as part of...
I think, in fact,
he's gonna call it Tapioca.
Or Tapioca ORM,
which has an R in it
for "Relational,"
even though there's nothing
relational going on,
which drives me nuts,
but anyway I couldn't get Erick
to change that.
Yeah,
so it'll be a library.
You'll be able to--
It's for the Java version
of App Engine right now.
I asked, "Will this work
for Python too?"
They said no.
Sorry.
So if you're writing
App Engine apps in Java,
you'll be able to use it
as a library,
as an open-source library.
Yeah.
Please.
Hey, Ryan.
Barrett:
Hey, Dan.
So you talked a little bit
about roll-forward.
And so most people,
myself included,
have more background with
rollback than roll-forward.
Do you want to talk about
the difference between the two
and why this is roll-forward?
Wilkerson:
Oh, right.
Ryan's the one who suggested
that this be an optimistic
transaction protocol,
and I don't know if
I would have thought of that
without his suggestion.
In fact, he had to suggest it
to me repeatedly,
'cause I kept trying
to do it another way.
So that was very helpful.
So thanks, Ryan.
And I think
it's because of that
that we have roll-forward.
Basically, when
the client function is running,
if anything goes wrong,
abort.
Once the client function
is done,
now the client function
has basically created a map
where it did some reads
and it wrote them
to some writes.
It's just a finite diff
on your database.
And now all we have to do
is apply that diff.
Preserving atomicity
and isolation.
Well, the entire result
of what the client did,
that whole diff,
the change to the database,
that delta to the database,
is written in the database
as objects in the database.
It's in shadow objects.
It's in the distributed
transaction object.
There's no need--
Okay, so...
It still might fail,
because there's checks.
We have to get locks.
We have to check
read object version numbers,
and we have to get locks
on the written objects.
If any of that fails,
then your transaction's
gonna abort,
and we're gonna throw
the whole thing away.
But once you have locks
and you've checked
the version numbers,
at this point,
nothing can go wrong.
And my way of thinking
about what is two-phase commit,
in the first phase,
do all the work,
and get it set up
so that nothing can go wrong.
And phase two,
throw the switch.
That's basically what we do.
Once you have all the locks,
you've checked
all the version numbers,
nothing can go wrong.
So if you time out,
which happens on App Engine
all the time, right?
App Engine comes
and times you out.
There's no reason that we have
to abort your transaction.
In fact,
once you've started copying
shadow objects
to written objects
and you've copied
a few of them,
you can't go back.
It's in there.
You must roll forward
to completion.
There's no going back.
There's no way
for us to undo that.
So if you time out,
and another thread locks
on the same objects
or a background thread says,
"Hey, what's this old DT
from yesterday
doing lying around,"
those threads can roll you
forward to completion,
and there's nothing
that can go wrong
other than being delayed
by more timeouts.
Rollback would be,
I suppose, if, I don't know...
I had to learn
about databases in order to--
I'm trained as a theory guy
and a software guy
and maybe PL guy,
but I'm not a database guy,
or wasn't.
I don't know how
rollback works, actually,
so whatever it is,
we don't do it,
'cause I don't understand it.
Yeah. Please.
man: Hey.
I have two questions.
Wilkerson:
Please.
man: I don't quite
understand what you mean--
Wilkerson: Could you speak
a little bit closer to the mic?
man:
Oh, excuse me.
I don't quite
understand what you mean
when you say the DT is
synchronized when it's issued,
but not synchronized...
Wilkerson:
When it completes.
man:
Who sees what where?
I mean, what is--
Yeah.
Wilkerson:
Very good.
Thank you.
Great question.
If I'm the client code,
I have two parts.
I have the caller code,
which says,
"Gee, I need to update--
I need to send $10
from Alice to Bob."
Then that code, your code,
calls, "Run
indistributed transaction,"
my code,
but you hand me a function
called transfer,
with arguments
Alice, Bob, and $10.
So then I run your function
for you, okay?
So that's all synchronous.
You called me,
I called your function back.
You know,
that's normal code.
If function F
calls function G,
function F pauses,
function G
gets a new stack frame.
Function G returns.
Function F then resumes.
That's all synchronous.
That's what you're used to.
However,
if you tell me
to run your function in
a distributed transaction,
what can happen is
while that's happening,
your code can take so long
or there can be so many delays
in the database,
it can all timeout.
Google can come
and just time you out.
And then boop, it's timed out.
There's nothing
I can do about that.
That's part of the constraints
of App Engine.
However,
that distributed transaction,
if it got far enough,
it's in there in the database.
It just hasn't applied yet.
So some other thread
may discover it.
In fact, the user
will probably hit reload,
or, "What the heck?"
And they'll say,
"What happened?"
Somehow your user
will come an interact
with the database again.
Your calling code
ought to query the database,
find any pending
distributed transactions
by that same user
that haven't completed yet,
and go,
"Hey, I didn't finish this."
And then call us and go,
"Hey, finish
rolling that forward."
That might timeout again.
Some background thread
might find it
and finish rolling it forward.
In any case,
the completion,
you never quite know
when it's gonna happen,
'cause your code
could take ten hours,
and every ten seconds
App Engine's timing you out.
So there could be a lot
of different threads
that have to discover that,
roll it forward a bit further.
Finally it completes.
It'll complete who knows when,
but whenever it completes,
your threads may not be around.
Somebody else's threads
maybe have tried to lock
one of the same objects
and have
rolled it forward for you
and completed it for you.
Now it's sitting there
in the database, completed.
And it's sitting there.
"I'm complete."
Then your user comes back...
and you find it lying around,
and you go, "Ah,
this completed asynchronously.
It completed some other time."
And there's really
no way around this.
If you write code
that takes long enough,
there's no way I can prevent,
in the presence of timeouts,
there's no way
I can prevent the need
for sometimes asynchronous
completes to happen.
So it'll complete.
If it completes synchronously,
if you say, "Run this,"
and it completes synchronously,
you get the distributed
transaction object back,
and it has a return value.
This is my recommended idiom
that they do
in the implementation.
It would have the return value.
If it failed,
it would have why it failed,
the exception value.
It would also have
the function you called.
So you could say,
"You were trying to do what?
"Oh, yesterday you were trying
"to send $10
from Alice to Bob.
"Oh,
let me put that in the UI.
"That thing
you tried to do yesterday,
"it completed.
Let me send that to you,
user."
So you could
complete synchronously,
but if you timeout,
you could complete
asynchronously,
and have to discover
that fact later.
With a query.
I thought about how--
And I'm not just a theory guy.
I thought about how
to write the code to do that.
And there's a nice way
to do it,
so you can discover things
to show 'em to the user.
man: So you're saying
we'll be able to query
the distributed
transaction itself
to ask it,
"Are you complete?" Or--?
Wilkerson:
You can query
the distributed transaction
infrastructure.
Go,
"Hey, does this user
"have any pending
distributed transactions
"lying around
that aren't done?
"Do those first,
"or tell me so that
I can tell the user.
"Or are there some
that are done,
and I should tell the user?"
You can query it for that.
man:
Well, the second one was,
if this works
as you say it works,
what would the point
of entity groups be in it?
Wilkerson: Because
you might have something
you can do with
only local transactions.
Those will be faster.
Our infrastructure costs you.
Man, we really
worked on it for months
to try to minimize the cost.
Erick put stuff in there.
Rob thought
of some optimizations.
We really tried
to minimize the impact.
But if you can do something
with only local transactions,
go ahead,
because they'll be faster.
man:
But, I mean, like,
you could put entity groups
around every single property,
what you're currently
putting around, like,
user spaces,
and it'd be the same with
distributed transactions.
Wilkerson:
You could put entity groups--
In fact, you can--
Erick was like,
"No, I want people
"to be able to use them both.
"And if you have
an entity group,
some objects can be distributed
transactions and some local."
I was like, "Erick,
nobody's gonna need that."
He's like, "No,
there's this optimization.
Sometimes you got
to group things for speed."
And he made it all work.
So you can have--
Evidently, he's told me
you can have an entity group.
Some objects in there
you do transactions
to the distributed
infrastructure.
And others you do with local.
But if you try to mix them,
it'll have to go
to distributed for all of them.
That answer your question?
man:
Yeah, thank you.
Wilkerson:
Cool.
We try to think of everything.
We really wanted it to work
in reality for you guys.
I spent a long time
trying to think of--
Yes, please.
man: So are you saying
that the application then
has to check
if there were transactions
that completed
but weren't...
What is it called?
Wilkerson:
The completed asynchronously.
You issued a request.
man: Yeah.
Wilkerson:
"In a distributed transaction,
please transfer $10
from Alice to Bob."
But for some reason,
that has
to go recompile Mozilla.
Okay,
so that takes a long time.
That doesn't return
in the timeout window.
You got, like, ten seconds,
is it, Ryan? Something?
Barrett:
30.
Wilkerson:
30 seconds.
Oh, they got generous.
Now you got 30 seconds
for it to do something,
you know?
But if it doesn't come back
in 30 seconds,
then it might still succeed,
but later.
If it does come back
in 30 seconds,
you get
a synchronous return back.
man:
So if it succeeds later,
do I still
have to have in my code
checks to see
if there are any pending ones
and then ask for them
to be completed?
Wilkerson:
Unless a background thread--
Somebody else's thread
or the background thread
may have done it for you,
but you still have to check--
Even if it got completed,
even if someone else
rolls them all forward for you
and they're all completed,
you still have to check--
"Hey, are there
any completed tasks
"that got done?
"Oh, well, thank you.
Let me tell the user."
'Cause how can I otherwise
tell you, right?
man: No, I'm thinking
if I don't care, right?
I've got this transaction
and it either succeeds
or fails, right?
Wilkerson: It will eventually
succeed or fail.
Unfortunately
it can starve---
Man: So I don't need
to do anything else?
Wilkerson: If you want
to absolutely make sure
it doesn't starve,
and you're kind of wondering
the background thread
might take a while
to get around,
you can do background stuff
in App Engine now.
If you want to rely
on the background thread
to find old distributed
transactions
and keep pushing on 'em
till they're done,
and that thing's
pretty aggressive,
then, yeah, there's nothing
you have to do.
It will abort
or it will succeed.
man:
All right.
Wilkerson:
Yeah.
One or the other,
eventually.
Yeah. Please.
man: Probably related
to his question was,
did you look at stability
as a factor
with these transactions?
I mean, the bane
in web applications
for the most part
is in instability
of the web applications
by complications, so...
Wilkerson: What do you mean
exactly by instability?
Like, a not reproducible--
like sometimes
takes a long time,
sometimes a short time?
man: Like applications
going offline
because they're clogged up
or they're destabilized
because of an
overly-complicated component
in the application server.
So did you take a look at that?
And then related to that--
Wilkerson:
Well, hold on.
I still don't understand.
What exactly
does instability mean?
What's the exact phenomenon?
Like,
you mean did we look at
if we make things take longer
and therefore
they're timing out
when they didn't used to?
man:
They're timing out,
and then the work required
to go remediate those
transactions
that are still
left running in the system.
In other words,
is there a consideration
of stability
in the application
in your design center
looking at this?
And related to that
is did you look at
any other technology
that's an alternative
to distributed transactions,
like technology provided by
business process
execution languages
that sort of compile, like,
a business process
into a...
you know, a simpler type
of back-end mechanism?
Wilkerson:
All right.
Both these questions
are kind of a little amorphous,
so I'll do my best.
In terms of instability,
what we did is,
we did the algorithm
that has the lowest impact--
Oh, I forgot.
There's something
I didn't put in a slide for.
It would have been
really easy to have read locks.
If you notice, our system
has no read locks.
So web apps
tend to be read-heavy,
as Ryan says.
So one thing that--
Several months ago,
I had an algorithm,
and I was like,
"All right.
It's done. It's baked."
We're way ahead of...
we're done.
But then I realized
I was getting read--
I had these read locks,
and I was getting read locks
on objects which I'd read,
which means if you read
in the distributed
transaction layer,
that was turning into a write
at the underlying
local transaction layer,
and I realized,
"That's really bad,"
because writes are always
way harder to handle than reads.
So we had to turn
the whole algorithm around
and spend a long time on this
just so that reads
at the distributed
transaction layer
turn into reads and no writes
on the underlying layer.
So if we hadn't done that,
this would be a piece of garbage
I think, probably.
And you would have
a very good point.
You'd say, well,
you just destabilized my app,
and you know what?
You'd probably be right.
But we've done
everything we can
to use the minimum resources
to make this happen.
We have not
implemented the latest thing
and done lots of performance
evaluation on it.
We haven't done that.
So we can find out
when you profile it.
Are there alternatives
to transactions?
Boy.
Could you not use transactions?
You could try to fold
the transactional semantics
into the actual
logic of your app
in such a way
that you just happen
to manipulate structures
in such a way
that they're kind of
doing transactions
and manipulations at once,
and kind of save the cost
of our layer.
Good luck.
I would never do that.
It's just too hard.
I don't know.
Alternatives to transactions,
It's an ongoing area
of research I think, actually.
Can anyone--Ryan, you know
a lot about this stuff.
Do you want
to say anything about that?
I think they probably want you
to talk into the mic, but...
Ryan says
there's a talk tomorrow
at 10:45 on offline processing,
and to go see that.
And, in fact,
you should probably stick around
for Ryan's talk,
which is next.
He's gonna tell you a lot
about App Engine infrastructure.
Yes, ma'am.
You have a question?
And, sir, if you want
to get at the mic, I can...
Go ahead and get to the mic.
Yes, sir.
Yes, ma'am.
woman: In Java,
you can specify something
to run in a transaction
and something to not
run in a transaction, right?
You provide two interfaces.
Wilkerson:
You can specify this--
"Do this in a transaction,
and then don't bother
with this other stuff," yes.
woman: Can you put a little more
highlight about that?
[speaks indistinct]
...In a transaction,
and to run in a transaction?
Wilkerson:
Oh, boy.
Can you say that again?
Did any--
I just didn't really
hear what you said, so...
maybe you can...
woman: So suppose
you specify something
to run in a transaction,
and some things to not run
in a transaction.
Can you give me
what will be the difference
in the state
of the two of them,
and what will be
the difference between them?
Wilkerson: Oh, how to know
what to do in a transaction?
Well, you explicitly say,
"Here's a function.
"Run that in a transaction
"with these arguments.
And then here's another one.
Do that one."
So you are explicitly
telling the program
what to run in a transaction.
Now the question is,
How do you know what to run
in a transaction
and what not to run
in a transaction?
Basically, as I said earlier,
you want to figure out
how you guarantee
the correctness
of your application.
What things
always have to be true?
The invariants.
Like your data structure.
You have a doubly-linked list.
Pointing like this, okay?
Whenever you go to--
If you start in a good state,
you know--
At this point in my code,
I'm in a good state.
All of my invariants are true.
At this point,
I'm at a good state again.
All my invariants are true.
But in between,
I might have to temporarily
inviolate an invariant.
I have to, like,
delete this pointer,
point it somewhere else.
Uh-oh.
Then I have to point
that pointer back to there.
Ah, now we're good again.
That, from a good state
to a good state,
that should be
in a transaction.
Yeah.
Very good question.
And there's a lot
of literature on that.
You go look at an
undergraduate database's book,
they'll probably
say a lot about that.
Sorry. Sir.
man: Sure.
Let's say
I built my application,
and I have various types
of objects to find
and I'm about to, you know,
I develop all my code
using regular,
in-built Google transactions,
and then I want to add--
But I know it's not reliable,
because I can't guarantee
that things will all commit
across
these various operations.
You know,
either all or none.
So then I add your framework
and your distributed
transactions.
How much longer will it take
for typical-use case
where I'm updating
a number of records,
inserting some, deleting some.
You know,
what's the overhead
of doing these
distributed transactions?
That's one thing.
Wilkerson:
What's the overhead?
I've got less than
one minute, unfortunately.
Unless they want
to let me go over.
Is there any chance
to go over or not?
No, she's shaking her head.
man: The other is
how intrusive is it to my code?
You know,
I've got my objects to find.
How much more do I need
to add?
How hard is it from
an engineering viewpoint?
I don't want to worry
about the details.
Wilkerson: I tried to make it
as easy to use as I could.
If you need transactions
to maintain
the correctness of your code,
there's no--I don't, like,
you have to use them.
So there's sort of a--
Not using them
is a bit of a red herring.
It's like you're
waiting for a disaster.
And in terms
of the performance,
I've got 20 seconds or so.
You know, for every read,
we actually do two reads.
For every write,
we actually do three writes.
And if you have
a read and a write
of the same object,
you get to save
one of those reads.
So if you read and write
the same object,
they have to do
three writes and one read.
So, yeah.
There's a constant multiple
on how many reads
and writes are going on,
but it's as small
as we can get it.
I'm pretty convinced myself
that there is no shorter way
to really do it.
And now I'm over. Okay.
The nice lady in the back
is telling me--
No? One more? Okay.
man:
I was just wondering
if there was any
resource constraints
on the distributed
transaction table.
Like, can you have
a limited number
open at any given time,
or is there
a rate of insert limit
like there are
on other tables?
Wilkerson:
It's gonna be--
I mean, a distributed
transaction object
is just an object
like any other object,
and it has any limits that
Google App Engine
has decided to put
on the number of objects
you can have.
man: So like
any other entity, basically.
Wilkerson:
It's one more entity, yes.
And they do go away.
So they are increasing
the amount of resource usage
of your app,
but when
the transaction completes
and the client code reads it
and says,
"Yep, that's complete.
Done. Delete that thing",
it shouldn't be using--
There shouldn't be any garbage.
There's one very rare case,
where I'm trying
to get rid of the--
It's an extremely rare case
where you might get
a little bit of garbage.
All right.
It looks like I'm out of time,
right, ma'am?
Yes, I am. Thank you.
[applause]